the siege is taking place in Sydney's
CBD or central business district
hostages are being held at the lindt
chocolate cafe in Martin place right in
the heart of the financial and shopping
center police have closed nearby roads
as well as the closest train station
Mart in place other public transport
routes have been diverted the street
itself is home to the state premier's
office the Reserve Bank of Australia and
a number of other large banks one of the
country's main broadcasters channel 7
has its Sydney office opposite the state
parliament house is a few blocks away as
are the highest Criminal Courts in New
South Wales which have been evacuated
and the cafe is less than half a mile
from some of sydney's most popular
tourist destinations including the
Harbour Bridge and circular key and the
iconic Sydney Opera House has also been
evacuated as a precaution